[Music]
many Bureau case file 5 six 6 seven -
Chester Hill white male age 73
deportation is scheduled for next
Tuesday at 9:00 a.m. as you know across
humanity euro new weed and will provide
you with the Fresh Start mental fool I
know the truth
high time did the White House was a
pretty good meal too little enthusiasm
for New Eden rumors of overcrowding and
disease
Chester health city knew the truth
Chester hills sad old man
Rachel Weller a single mother aged 30
son Lucas aged 11 to you and your son or
be transferred to the resettlement
colony of New Eden it's for the best
people are desperate can't find clean
water soil won't grow food why do you
want to stay here this is where my son
and I belong
[Music]
this will answer all of your questions
my brother and his wife were deported to
new even three years ago I haven't heard
from them since what have we done we
have to only take only what you can
carry
whatever cross is planning make sure he
doesn't succeed
anyone who approaches you will be
hostile he'll die if we head north
dad we stay here
ow
let the Revolution begin
you